barricadas se alinean en las calles de
la isla francesa de guadalupe las
protestas contra las restricciones para
el hobby 19 entraron en su segunda
semana la obligatoriedad del pase
sanitario y la vacunación de los
trabajadores de la salud impuestas en el
país han provocado disturbios en la isla
francesa donde se han registrado saqueos
nocturnos y enfrentamientos con la
policía el ministro francés de ultramar
recalcó que es escandaloso no acatar las
reglas impuestas en el país luego de
publicar el orden republicano debe
volver y el ministro del interior ha
anunciado importantes refuerzos ya que
por las noches los agentes de la ley son
víctimas de munición real esto es algo
que no podemos aceptar y debemos
condenar la violencia no tiene cabida en
el territorio de la república ni en
guadalupe ni en ningún otro lugar en los
últimos meses guadalupe se vio afectado
por una nueva ola de casos de kobe 19
que abrumó a los hospitales además la
pandemia también ha devastado la
industria del turismo la desconfianza en
las vacunas y la medicina natural son
populares en el caribe francés el enojo
de la población por la nueva restricción
los ha llevado a preguntas más amplias
sobre la relación del archipiélago con
parís
no no es una buena respuesta del
gobierno porque nos obligan a vacunar
nos será difícil pero seguiremos
movilizando nuestro menos de la mitad de
la población de guadalupe ha recibido
una dosis de la vacuna lo que es
incomparable con francia continental
donde el 75% de la población ya está
inmunizada la atención también se
intensifica en la vecina isla de
martinica donde la policía fue atacada
con disparos este martes